Joey is in San Bernardino hey Joey how
are you good good how are you better
than I deserve what's up um okay so
first off you've been like in my brain
next to Jesus for like ten years okay
I've been avoiding you at all costs
because I just always thought that you
were like not for having fun but truly I
was too young to understand and realize
I took your class about four times
dropped out three other times and
finally finished it years ago I still
never and never did anything with it
finally I just had a realization the
other day and I am really on track and I
think I'm going to be on track and so I
had just called because I finished Total
Money Makeover and I know that you said
if you're in back taxes make sure you
tackle those first so I mean because I
have I have student loans and I don't
know about the other things that I'm
behind on because it's been like like I
honestly have never made payments in
like ten years on those homework I'm 31
okay how long have you been working long
you've been out of school since 2012
mm-hm and what do you make last year I
made 98 thousand but I didn't pay any
taxes either so so you own your own
business yeah I do a lot of different
things
mm-hmm a lot of different things I mean
how'd you make 98 thousand I'm a first
I'm a respiratory therapist for home
care two days a week and then I'm a
professional photographer I shoot
weddings on the weekends and also a
videographer and I have a from the Bluth
company okay how can I help you
so I have like 3,000 left and arts are
nard Prius and I can pay it all off next
month and then we have about 6,000 left
on our Honda and I want to take those
out this year and then just do I just go
straight after the taxes and not worry
about school loans or until I get the
taxes then how much do you owe in taxes
after this year it'll probably be around
50
thousand well this year's only half-done
yeah how much do you owe in taxes now
for half the year so far I bet it's
probably gonna be so far like twelve
thousand it's just this year's taxes
that I'm assuming I got back I don't
know you don't have back taxes from last
year yeah I do I have twenty thousand
from laughing this one am i okay okay
okay all right well the first thing you
need to do is set up an accounting
system for your businesses okay
separate checking account for each
business and only put money into the
respiratory account from the respiratory
business only put photography money into
the photography account period okay that
don't right there listen now listen
listen okay and don't write any checks
out of any of those accounts except
expenses associated with that so you
don't pay respiratory business expenses
out of the photography account and you
don't buy groceries out of the
photography account you only write
expenses associated with a photography
account so follow me on this if only
income goes into the photography account
from photography and only photography
expenses come out then your your
checkbook register essentially becomes a
profit and loss statement you can tell
if that business is making money when
you any money that's left in that
account by definition is profit on cash
basis accounting okay so when you get
ready to take money out of that account
I want you to set aside 1/4 of it for
your quarterly estimates now once you
start paying quarterly estimates
immediately okay going for all your
money going forward starting today every
dime you make okay and it's going to be
about 1/4 of your income and so if you
set aside 25% you pull out you know
$10,000 and you set aside 2,500 bucks
out of that account for taxes and take
7,500 and put it in your home account to
pay bills with but you set aside you
withhold taxes on yourself about 25% of
what you're doing and then you'll have
the money to pay your Quarterly's going
forward because you can't dig your way
out of last year's tax
while digging into this year's taxes you
got to stop the bleeding first yeah then
you can heal okay so first thing is set
up an accounting system start doing your
quarterly estimates get in touch with
one of our endorsed local providers and
lay out a game plan for doing your
quarterly estimates properly so you
don't get yourself in a pinch again okay
Xena okay we've got the money left over
after your quarterly taxes you're
withholding on yourself whatever is left
over is now your income and that's the
take-home pay that everybody else
operates on you know you said you're
married yeah and does she have an income
no she's a stay-at-home okay and so we
take the money from you know the there's
take-home pay and we begin to clear this
up then what I would do is I clear up
taxes first before I pay off your cars
before I pay off your student loan I'd
go back and get that $20,000 done as
soon as possible because the IRS has the
highest interest rates the highest
penalties and the most powers screw up
your freakin life okay I do not want
these people in your life okay then
start your debt snowball once you get
that $20,000 from last year cleared up
and you can do that pretty quickly once
you get on a system and you decide if
you're really as disgusted as you're
trying to convince me you are yeah if
you're really disgusted enough to
finally change you can the numbers tell
me you can walk through this but it's
what Chris Hogan says all the time the
numbers change when people do so you're
42 false starts is this going to be
another one are you really gonna do it
this time I think you're really gonna do
it because I think I've heard enough
healthy disgust in your voice you got
tired of out trying to out earn your own
stupidity I try to do that for a long
time it's very difficult you gotta make
a lot of money doubt on your stupidity
it's a lot of money most people can't do
it most people are stupid me included
you just can't do that you got to stop
being stupid this is the Dave Ramsey
shop